hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from the 38th
European Club cup we have a game between
magnus's club overshpiel and the club uh
called what's called wood green and the
Magnuson board one faces uh English
Grand Master Hari ravia and um Magnus
playing for authors pill is pretty much
the only opportunity uh players that are
not rated like 2700 maybe 26.50 will get
a chance to play against him as he will
play a couple of games on on board one
and uh it truly is an amazing
opportunity Magnus usually plays only
close tournaments and sometimes okay if
it's maybe in a in a country that
organizes it maybe out of the 10 or 8
players they invite maybe one or two
will be a rated 26 something but other
than that Magnus usually only face a
stop opposition so great opportunity for
honey and um uh Hardy's I believe 22
year old he's an English Grandmaster and
he even wrote a book called The
modernized anti-sicilians volume one the
rossolimo variation uh which would be
great if he had the white piece but he
has black here against Magnus so we'll
see what he does and for this game uh
Magnus opened with Ponte E4 now Hari
went for pontes sorry Ravi went for
Ponte E6 he goes for the French defense
D4 D5 and now Ponte E5 Magnus goes for
the advanced variation against the
French C5 and now Pawn to C3 so this is
the top move and of course uh uh both of
them play only top moves in the opening
unlike the game that I played in the
previous video Knight F3 Bishop to D7
and now Bishop to E2 and here uh the
main ideas are Knight um uh GTA E7 and
also uh you could uh you could just play
Pawn to F6 attack the white center right
away but he starts with a capture C
captures on D4 we have C captures and
non-night gt7 uh when Magnus played E5
he went for the advanced variation but
he also gave up the F5 Square so aravi
will uh use this Square for his Knight
we have castles Knight to F5 and now
Knight the C3 and here we have Pawn to
A6 now I I think I've already mentioned
this a few videos back but some of you
uh have problems with Queen to B6 that
puts pressure on D4 and also on B2 so
you can't play Bishop D3 but you can
just kick away the queen with Knight A4
the queen has to go back and then you
play something like Bishop F4 uh if the
queen persists like Queen A5 you just
harass the queen and then once the queen
finally goes back you will play Bishop
to F4
if you play Bishop G5 then the queen
will just return to the A5 Square so
Bishop F4 is the square for the bishop
here so after Knight C3 uh he goes A6
and now we have Bishop to G5 by Magnus
and queen to B6 is the only move that
has been played in this position but
here we have Bishop D7
and is now as of move tender we have a
completely new game and Magnus very
happily exchanges the dark Square
Bishops and you will soon see why so
Bishop captures Queen captures and queen
to D2 so now Magnus has a light score
bishop and Ravi has a light screw Bishop
but Magnus put his pawns on dark squares
that means that this bishop can be very
useful in this diagonal whereas this
bishop uh will have to figure out how it
can be useful in this game so here we
have castles uh Rook a to E1 and now
Queen to d8 uh with Bishop to D1 by
Magnus Shifting the bishop over to this
diagonal uh and now Pawn to F6 this is a
Black's uh plan always you have to
attack the E5 pawn bishop to A4 now
Magnus is uh sort of asking will you
play F characters on E5 because if you
do I'm gonna capture on C6 first and
once Bishop capture CS Magnus gave up
the good Bishop but then the monster
Knight lens on E5 it's on a dark square
and black will have a very hard time
dealing with this knight uh you will
probably at some point have to play
something like 97 to G6 to get rid of it
uh then Magnus will probably consolidate
and then he will start getting his Rooks
into the game and so on so after Bishop
A4 B5 is played with Bishop back to C2
and now F captures an E5 D captures an
E5 and now King to h8
um
although you can play D4 right away now
it's not the best Magnus will just
attack the pawn and once you defend it
okay now you are defending it but uh
something like Bishop to E4 and you
already have a weird position so uh not
interested in that that Ravi goes for
King to h8 Knights to E2 and now we have
Knight to H4 going for an exchange of
knights which is great for black so
Knight captures Queen captures and now
Magnus plays Pawn to F4 so okay he's
just keeping the tension he defends his
Pawn on E5 and he's just saying I have a
monster Bishop you have a weird Bishop
on D7 and if uh actually if we moved
both of these Bishops off the board then
Black's position would improve immensely
but that's easier said than done Rook a
to C8 and the Magnus just moves it back
to B1 and now Queen to H6 not allowing
any advances as the queen on D2 would
hang so Queen to E3 first by Magnus now
also having some ideas of maybe
infiltrating on the queen side not for
the moment but uh you know it's a useful
thing to have and between the H4
now you can't really go for a rock lift
as the rook and E1 would hang so Rook
the C1 putting the Rook on the only open
file on the board and now while you
could play something like G6 this is a
very committal move and you are
weakening your king side so Ravi just
brings the queen back Queen to E7 uh and
now Magnus has to decide how to deal
with this but Queen t7 is sort of a
sub-optimal move as it allows Magnus to
play Queen to H3 threatening Checkmate
on H7 don't forget about our good friend
the bishop on B1 so H6 and here Magnus
played something that is really really
strange I when I uh checked on the games
this was the position on the board when
I checked on my phone and I thought okay
Bishop Queen D3 and black resigns and I
was very much uh uh amazed that Magnus
did not play this and later I checked
it's actually the strongest move
recommended by the engine uh but not
because of what I thought uh I thought
okay Queen D3 black resigns uh but of
course because if you play something
like King J then you just get checkmated
nothing weird happening here but the
real move for black is G5 and now Queen
guards H7 and already it's a
double-edged position
in order to actually win this you have
to play Rook seat to E1 uh really weird
move uh so uh you have to move the Rook
off of the C1 Square so if the Knight
moves uh you don't have to worry about
any Rook captures and C1 ideas and now
while everything is defended you will go
for a rock lift and uh easily win the
game but Magnus does not play that he
plays a YOLO move he plays Pawn to G4
and now again it's incredibly difficult
to define the move for black here the
the thread is G5 and the only move that
sort of keeps you in the game is Rook to
G8 but uh I mean who plays this in a
position like this so we have Pawn to D4
trying to get active maybe you get this
bishop on this diagonal somehow and also
maybe you can advance this Pawn but it
doesn't work and again Magnus doesn't
play Queen to D3 which is winning he
plays Pawn to A3 and I have no idea why
he played Ponte A3 nothing comes to mind
uh maybe he went so deep into the
position and saw it okay maybe just
controlling the B4 square is you useful
it gives you the support for advancing
your own Pawn to be four stops black
from going B4 but other than that I have
no idea yeah but yeah Queen to D3 was uh
that was enough to win but the Magnus
says Nope my position is winning I'm
just going to put every piece and Pawn
on on the optimal Square because before
I force the black to resign so King to
G8 was played Now Pawn to G5 and here uh
Bishop to E8 sort of still holds Black's
position for example after captures you
have to play G6 but it's a really really
bad position for black so instead Ravi
went for Knight captures on E5 it's a PO
it's a b sacrifice
um hoping to get some Queen captures and
G5 action in uh but Magnus just shows
that it will not work Rook captures on
C8 Bishop captures and now he takes the
piece F captures on E5 Queen captures on
G5 with check and now Queen to G3
offering a queen trade as he's up a
piece Rook captures on F1 King captures
and now Queen to D2 so very active queen
and magnus's king is very very much
exposed but Magnus just played Bishop to
G6 and he was in this position on move
32 that Ravi hariya resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
looks like okay the white king is white
in the open maybe you can throw in some
checks but you really can't this is
covered by the Knight discovered by the
queen and the Knight you could play
Queen D1 check but after that um I mean
nothing really happening after King to
F2 and other than that um
uh really not that much and look at the
bishop the light the the difference in
light Square Bishops this light Square
Bishop you know an absolute Monster uh
where is this light Square Bishop locked
in its room for the entire game not
really not really being a part of this
game uh he did try advancing the pawn to
get it on this diagonal somehow uh but
they're just uh there just wasn't a good
time to do that so uh in a lot of these
lines like in a lot of lines of the
Queen's Gambit declined for example you
will have uh you have to know the exact
way how to you know solve your problem
of the light Square bishop and this is
also one such example uh where Magnus
just completely dominated the light
Square bishop and there was nothing uh
he could do like if you if you play
Bishop to B7 now okay you control this
diagonal and it's very nice but Queen H4
and you know the thread of Checkmate is
just too great you you can still give
only one check there's nothing for you
to do you can give one check and after
King F2 uh there's no stopping Queen to
d8 that's that's just it
so really a positional Masterpiece by
Magnus a good opportunity for Ravi to do
something but uh you know you you see
how difficult it is he played great he
played uh very interesting moves he even
uh you know went into some Sidelines the
the surprise Magnus but the light Square
Bishop the difference in light Square
Bishops was just too incredible uh for
anyone to handle
uh sir uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh magnus's first game in
this year's uh European Club cup we'll
probably cover all of them if they will
be interesting and for me this is very
very interesting uh so yeah that's the
game hope you enjoyed it I would like to
wish a very happy birthday to Jeff and I
would like to thank Robert arathon Kumar
Kate Ingram and Bernardi for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and do check
out my previous video from the women's
under 20 World Championship it's quite a
brutal brutal game involves a wonderful
Queen sacrifice uh see you soon